to do a family waiting and wondering
when they can go home mom and dad the
kids age four six and nine and their 63
year old grandfather the Pearson family
forced to flee their homes in the middle
of the night to get away from a raging
Wildfire
it was very stressful we were all
running around the house to collect our
belongings we tried to grab some food
clothes medicine
they've been told their house is still
standing Untouched by the Flames at
least so far
it has been very dry and hot this year
so we knew something like these fires
could happen so I think the government
was prepared to evacuate people before
the fire started the Pearson family is
now among about 50 people living
temporarily in this Sports Arena that
has been converted into a shelter in the
town of roberval 250 kilometers to the
south of where the fires are burning a
few days ago there were 400 evacuees
here but many have left to stay with
friends or family
for the first time in several days there
seems to be some hope here in Quebec and
that's in part to the weather a light
rain is falling helping to suppress the
wildfires and bring down the smoke at
one point over 130 fires were burning in
Quebec but local officials say they are
finally starting to get many of them
contained
that's good news for the Pearson family
as well as other evacuees
the first thing I will do when I go back
home is check if everything is okay in
my house after that I will see if my
life can return back to normal how it
was before and think about how to live
life again
now starting to think about returning
home as soon as it's deemed safe
although everyone here is aware that
Canada's six-month long fire season has
only just gotten underway
Gabriel Elizondo Al Jazeera roberville
Quebec Canada